it's on the way damned Viper thanks Paul
control to pilot titanfall is much more
than just call of duty with mex sure
it's an easy enough comparison to make
some of the biggest names of respawn
came over from infinity ward and the two
games do share a frantic fast-paced
style of action but the similarities end
there titanfall is fresh distinct and
very much its own thing it all starts
with how you move around the map as a
pilot running around on foot you're
nothing short of an acrobat you can dash
along Wars and use your rocket pack to
double jump in midair chain these two
abilities together and there's hardly a
building you can climb in a few seconds
flat this fluid high-flying style of
movement opens up each map incredible
new ways plus you can drop kick people
in midair hey yeah hey you're turning
brother wife or husband
just how mobile you are depends on how
you set your loadout add the enhanced
arc work it and you can dash along walls
for even longer periods of time pair
that with the stim pack ability and
you'll be running at super speeds with
the top of a button of course you don't
have to play like a meth adult speed
freak the cloak ability lets you sneak
around unseen for a brief period of time
while the explosives pack turns you into
a one-man demolition crew but all of
that load out stuff we've seen it all
before where titanfall really paves new
ground is in the way it layers all these
different levels of conflict within a
single match you've got pilot versus
pilot pilot versus type you tighten
versus tighten and that's before you get
into the AI soldiers there are micro
battles and macro battles and it's all
thanks to those big adorable robots so
here's a Titans work you begin each
match with a countdown timer when that
timer reaches zero you get to call down
your very own personal Robo suit but the
better you do in combat the faster that
timer decreases and the sooner you get
to hop into your Titan so this means
you're encouraged to kill both enemy
players and to farm the AI soldiers
which kind of function like the creeps
you'd see in a MOBA inside of your Titan
it's a different experience altogether
aside from the quick dash ability that
operates on a cooldown timer your
movements are slow and methodical you
have to quite literally pick your
battles because the only way out of a
losing fight is the eject button that
sends you launching into the sky when
you're ready to abandon your Titan
that said you do have some pretty badass
abilities as a Titan the vortex shield
allows you to grab bullets which are
fired at you and return them to sender
you can equip the nuclear rejection park
to set off a giant nuclear blast when
you abandon ship or fire off a glass of
electrical smoke for a bit of light
chemical warfare these are powerful
machines but what's remarkable about it
all it's just how well balanced
everything feels sure Titans can punch
pilots into bloody explosions of gore
but pilots can also jump on Titans and
rodeo them for a relatively easy kill l
one of the most basic parts of the pilot
loadout is choosing which anti Titan
weapon to start with there's one game
mode where the pilot versus Titan
dynamic gets flipped on its head and
it's called last Titan standing it's a
bit like counter-strike both teams start
out as Titans and when you die you're
done for the round the winning team is
the one with the last type and standing
of course if you reject it before your
Titan explodes you can still run around
causing havoc on foot rodeoing opposing
Titans as you try and tip the odds in
your team's favor other game modes
include attrition which is basically
team deathmatch and hard point
domination which is well basically
conquest or domination depending on your
shooter of choice the unique thing about
these modes is the way matches end with
a brief epilogue the losing team calls
in for an evac ship and anyone who can
hightail it back to the ship on time
gets a consolation prize in the form of
bonus xp but the winning team can still
shoot down the ship so it tends to be a
chaotic exercise in running for your
life however if you do make it out is
the lone survivor boy does that feel
sweet and that's titanfall in a nutshell
it's a fast-paced game with a whole lot
going on but all the different
strategies and battles with in battles
make it feel like something totally new
in the world of first-person shooters
make sure you check gamespot over the
coming days and weeks for even more
features on one of the biggest games of
2014 titan forum
thank you
3s you're unstable
all right we got what we came for
awesome work team mission accomplished